Oh Oh what is up
so first I want to say thank you so much
for coming out I think this is hot ones
fourth ever complex con but this one to
me it's the most special because it's
here in Chicago Illinois a place that I
consider home let's make some noise for
the best damn city in the world
[Applause]
alright so today's guest in addition to
headlining the weekend's event he's a
platinum-selling artist in his latest
album death race for love debuted at
number one on the Billboard charts
earlier this year let's make some noise
for Chicago's own juice world all right
you'll be on this side I'll take this
side and it's a time crunch so we'll
just jump right into it with our first
wave which is the classic let's start at
the handle how you doing what's your
mindset like right now I heard about you
[Laughter]
now
that's the way to do it code it so right
there whoo all right so I want to start
off with your gear head side because I
know that you have a garage that's full
of motorbikes and then even your latest
project the cover art and pays homage to
that demolition derby video game
franchise twisted metal mm-hmm have you
ever suffered road rash or any kind of
injury messing around on those things
no no no no it's not hi yeah that's what
I'm not I ain't going out like that I
look I just had a mouthful use him so
you know it's polite to chew first you
know um we're riding up and down the
street and there's like this part of the
street that it's not really a sharp turn
but it's you kind of gotta slow down for
you know little tricky yeah yeah yeah
and it's no monk my girl outside all my
homies outside
showoff so I hit the UH I hit the turn
and the bike stays right here but I go
flying off and I'm pants first and it
was all flooding and stuff it can be a
dangerous game all right well there it
is are you ready to move on to wing
number two might as well yellow it is
the sauce pay wing to what it's called
sauce babe oh I know what you say it is
now right so wait wait wait wait wait
his rap was really only crying over the
wall we're only the second wing in let's
all remember that juice world said this
yeah yeah remember so a lot of people
obsess over sneakers or jewelry but here
at first we feast we're more interested
in which rappers have the rarest most
exotic cereal collections have you ever
had that cereal that's just powdered
hostess doughnuts like yeah we yeah so
that's a classic one and I know a lot of
stuff I fell in love with that said I
was eating it like every day for like
two weeks probably and then off the
topic of cereal but still on food
another year Chicago guy are you a shark
Skye are you a heralds get heroes Harold
sharks is like the not like it's Versace
and his versus sharks just like the vs.
version I do or you're not good at those
some Helsby versus USP a no excellent
food take from juice world are you ready
to move on third wings shaquan - shaquan
goes huh it's good it's good it was not
hot though not tested yet so sticking to
the topic of Chicago I think that it's
only right here at complex con that we
shout out Chief Keef what does that name
mean to you
shouts Oh song I mean it's just crazy to
see that somebody shooting a video with
a friends when they blocked with it
front to end up you know being on charts
and going platinum they have his songs
with you know Kanye I'm saying right and
and and me being a music head that I was
and still am I studied the stuff like
losing with my life for a long time and
then Chicago is obviously left an
enduring imprint on hip hop from the
sounds to these new flows that have
eventually taken over the whole genre so
on the topic of Chicago hip hop was your
top five better alive man top five that
I love Kanye I gotta give it a chance to
modern day man I'll put them on the spot
the wings might not make him sweat but
right listen certain questions right oh
I say Kanye Chas MC juice you know that
is he's the only MC old school MC the
only person to ever be Eminem in a rap
battle if I'm not mistaken there you go
something that have seen juice I mean I
had to say herb to people be sleeping on
Fredo but that's one one of the more
influential people come out of Chicago -
all right well there it is
juice world's top 5 dead or alive are
you ready to move on lucky dog you're
the dog our forth wing yeah
[Music]
song he was just struggling there you
are I'm okay I'm gonna Hank I'm sure
that's so far so far so from what I
understood maybe not good this is my
show now
welcome to hot once we train so from
what I understand you travel with three
pieces of luggage one for your clothes
one for your sneakers and then one for
your video games what is the mobile
gaming setup like for juice world a
setup visit me praying at the team you
got a hdmi cord right
three love you don't tell me yeah if
it's the oldest system the red white and
yellow course which video game do you
think has the best soundtrack of all
time Tony hope Tony ha for ya Tony hard
that was Jean I got a question for you
though
sure so I heard that you carry around
three pieces of luggage well for your
clothes facts one for your shoes and
then third one for your hot sauces you
know you have to have it ready you know
if you run into juice world at complex
con you have to have that third bag
ready so you can pop up the show for the
people you know told y'all is my show
that's how I get cuz that's how it goes
all right are you ready to move on to
the halfway point here we are with
Lowe's calientes number five light work
life work all right so here at the
halfway mark the hot ones fans here you
know we do a recurring segment called
explain that Graham juice world we've
done a deep dive on your Instagram fold
interesting pictures that need more
context and I love doing this at complex
con because we have monitors it makes
this feel like a real production it's so
exciting
now for the put me on blast so let's put
up the first picture it's you throwing
out the first pitch at a White Sox game
I actually threw out the first pitch at
yesterday's Cubs game airmailed it Arab
air mailed it and hit a staffer and hit
a staffer so I was wondering if you have
any notes how did this go for you uh I
actually grew up playing baseball so and
we do but you know what it's a different
story what do you get at first I mean I
pitched towards the end of my baseball
career and I had speed but I had no
control
I throw two strikes and then like get
all up in my head and then I'm hitting
do in the faces on
it happens like that sometimes I know
they'd be like that don't mm-hmm all
right let's pull up the next picture
here you are with a Japanese face mask
can you break down the skincare routine
once and for all for the people here at
complex guy yeah I got one word
exfoliate exfoliate words to live by
from juice rolled and let's pull up the
final picture here you are playing chess
yeah are you a chess guy because you do
have that song chess King I just really
I won't want them students that could
just sit in classrooms just dumps and
just like and like I couldn't learn that
way so just in case I thought they knew
it all and every time we had getting
into like a little knock kids get into
hearts occasions yep hey you so dumb and
you so hot start beating everybody in
chess they couldn't call me dumb and you
don't never do your homework
oh my you just lost to somebody ain't
never do a homework assignment they like
checkmate checkmate checkmate all right
juice world you ready to move on war
already sir all right this one we have
Detroit Hellfire say this from a male
huh
I'm good not hot so you have a
reputation for sale like you struggling
though for real you know I've been doing
this now many for a long long time 9c
supposed to be the Guru right yeah but
you know what you put those city miles
on you eventually the car starts to
break down a little bit you know all
right so you have a reputation for being
a beast in the studio from doing these
one-take freestyles to completing albums
in a matter of days with these manic
from dusk till dawn studio sessions and
then you know critics they have a lot to
say about SoundCloud rappers but when
you break it down it really is like the
best sink or swim platform in music
right now
what do critics get wrong in your
opinion when they pigeonhole either the
artists or the songs that pop on
soundcloud oh I think when they go wrong
is a person may make a song or a project
and anybody who's criticizing it takes
that song or project or whatever you
know piece of art that was and then
label that artist to say okay autumn
usik is gonna sound like this audio
music no just making an assumption based
off one piece of art they are the artist
is somebody then that expresses
themselves not necessarily in one way
you know like me for example I could
make a rap song right and in and within
the same hour or have somebody set up a
guitar pop or drums and make something
that sounds like it came from all no
warped or 2005 or some [ __ ] right that's
no I think that's where critics are
wrong all right juice roll are you ready
to move on to number seven Trinidad
scorpion from Wilshire Chile farm yeah
that tastes like this one to be a
problem like though you say oh oh so
we've talked about video games in your
Chicago roots but I want to take a wing
to explore some of those larger
influences of juice world in like five
seconds well sure and maybe you can just
think about this while you take down the
lemonade are you still into Percy
Jackson novels yeah I started reading
them like third grade
come put them down after that damn bro
let's go [ __ ] for the uninitiated why is
Percy Jackson better than Harry Potter
oh no hold on alright so look hey
particle look intimidating to certain
people because it's like a big series
and you kind of got to read a little bit
to get into it you know Percy Jackson
the action started right away
oh my [ __ ] on 1000 why do you think that
there's such a strong connections you
wrap an anime for artists like you would
done sell curry the interest the
connection to it goes much deeper than
Dragon Ball Z yeah I mean this part of
my escape as a kid you know so it's
always hold a special place in my heart
I can tell you my enemy though okay [ __ ]
you ever heard of my hero academia no no
it's like a high school for superheroes
I want to maybe do that but a high
school for like supervillains I like the
sound of that I like the sound of that a
high school for supervillains let's make
some noise for juice world going into
dabomb which for the hot ones fans here
is a moment they've been waiting for
wait
I still got ammo left bro hey here's the
bomb beyond insanity well this ain't
right be careful here you getting a
small bite that's it this [ __ ] too hot
bro no what no it's not I take that back
come on top of it alright so one of the
crazy byproducts of the internet age is
that rappers they can build this massive
cult following before ever even taking
the stage do you remember your first
show and whether or not you got paid for
it yeah my first show I got paid $100
for at a rec center and a south suburbs
yeah and then I know that you just
finished Wireless and now you're about
to hit this UK tour circuit what are
some of the challenges of now going to
these massive festival stages we were
playing in front of fields of thousands
of people if there's out the country the
only challenge is finding good food to
eat which is tough to do right very hard
to do I always living off McDonald's a
day hey man it's not funny oh no way 11
that was a who oh I wish Alko feel this
gee I've heard you say that you don't
enjoy performing lucid dreams which is a
billboard number-one hit with the
bajillion streams if can you unpackage
that I'll still love that song that's
always part of reason why I blew up but
okay I mean you perform the same thing
every day you want to show to people
something new so give the people more
new music alright are you trippin - yeah
you and me we're in this together just
world this is a buddy cop movie with
chicken wings that we are now taking
towards the end how are you doing oh and
talk about all right so this next one is
the chocolate plague the what the pucker
but pepper company chocolate play found
this we found this in the in the
suitcase in the luggage bag full of hot
sauces do you always see that name and
just fit a lot Bob picked this well we
saw the name and we're like that's the
sauce that we make
- so do we have any ice in that ice
needle let's say all right [ __ ]
that's the wing that makes the rappers
cry you know ain't crying I was good I'm
gonna be honest look yeah I was good all
the way up until you see how the fight
started getting smaller long yeah I've
noticed that Jesus Christ let's make
some noise
all right
oh we also be blowing we're on we're
going the mumbles there last one right
mm-hmm
but my lips is on fire bro no you doing
me both I can't go to hell cuz I can't
even take this oh I call the imagine how
I feel Oh y'all that's clapping I expect
all y'all to be patting my back when I'm
in the bathroom keep that same energy
ball so when blink-182 announcing but
they were going on tour with Lil Wayne
there are a lot of music bloggers that
were like oh my god that's such a random
pairing but my guess is you were not one
of them do you see a connection between
pop punk and rap oh yeah hold on let me
tell you why I said um a lot of rappers
are kind of putting different genres in
a music and I feel like one of the first
jar was that people reached to is plump
pot and then that rap/rock crossover it
has a deep history going all the way
back to Run DMC and Aerosmith eesti boys
and now here with you juice world and it
has varying degrees of success like we
just talked about very successful
projects but there are some with you
know mixed results why is the rock rap
crossover where the challenge is there
why is that so difficult I mean because
no offense but sometimes we coming out
corny you can tell when someone wanting
some
he really has it in them and what
somebody's just reaching all right it's
not them
speaking of reaching I'm reaching for
this last bottle on up
you're probably wondering oh and the
reason why is because this is the last
dab we call it the last dab because it's
tradition around here to put a little
extra on the last wing you don't have to
if you don't want to let's make some
noise it's not as not easy in a live
setting with all these people out there
I'm skipping that's a good that's a good
damn that's a good dog careful all right
ice cups coming in at just the right
time
let me get ice cube a saucer here you go
a little my brother there we go alright
let this sit there for supper
go alright here we go
bottoms up tenth wig the last dab boom
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what those alright
juice world here we are at the end of
our spicy wing journey the fourth in
complex town history most impressively
of all is that juice world is gonna hit
the main stage shortly and that is the
real wing 10 challenge here but before
we get you out of here how do you think
taking down ten scorching hot chicken
wings might affect your live performance
hello I guess we'll see huh we will find
out in just a few short hours let's make
some noise for juice world and let's
make some noise for yourselves here we
are forth complex con in hot ones
another one for the history books
hold up you want to launch a shirt we
got shirts we got shirts here you go
you'll get a last step
hey you'll get a last step let me get
some oh you'll get a last step here here
[Music]
the pasties No yeah yeah Pass about I
know laughs oh there you go starting a
feeding frenzy thank you very much
good job vegan hey what's going on hot
ones fans this is Sean Evans checking in
to say thank you so much for watching
today's episode but I have a stern
warning for those of you out there
who've been watching us now for nine
seasons and have still not subscribed
this is your final warning subscribe or
else
[Music]
[Music]